Oh, hello there! I didn't see you there, but I'm so glad you're here because I would like to thank the ice cream truck drivers.
Thank you so much, ice cream truck drivers. Who are the ice cream truck drivers?
Well, these are the folks that deliver that ice cream straight to your ear holes.
Right now, I'd like to thank Jonathan, Jeff Harris, Jason Klepper, Jake Schneider, Jacob Dinkelaker, I Wanna Scoop Baby, Ice Blue Scoop,
and Galactic President Scooper Star McScoops-A-Lot.
If you want to be an ice cream truck driver just like these fine folks, head over to PreachingFun.com.
PreachingFun.com is where you can go sign up to be an ice cream truck driver, and who knows, the life you save may be your own.
Could be... could be. Here's the show!
Hey, Johnny! Do you want to go to an ice cream social?
Yeah, I'd love to!
Great! Let's go!
Alright.
How many guys do you need here? No problem, here we go!
Good to see you here!
Everything's fine!
It's time for Matt Maddly's Ice Cream Social!
Sitting in Las Vegas, that's Matt Donnelly!
Sitting in Pittsburgh, PA, and it's Paul Maddingly!
Sitting in Las Vegas, it's me, Jacob the Audio Guy!
We're PreachingFun!
Yeah!
You know, like, it is kind of like, for desk, ScoopFest tends to always be around some fiery times.
It sure does!
Well, the Scoopocalypse actually got cancelled because of the fucking thing!
We cancelled the Scoopocalypse!
Yeah, because of an apocalypse!
And I remember having Penn on, you know, when Trump got elected and stuff.
It was the very first time. It was crazy.
And I, you know, I actually only got a direct hateful email once for talking about politics on this show from a listener.
Okay!
And it was when I said, "If you don't want to vote, if you want to sit out this election, vote for Joe Biden."
And the reason why is because your life will simply be easier.
I said, "You simply elect a guy who doesn't demand to command the news cycle, morning, news, and night."
Leading into Trump's second run for president, right?
When he was running against Biden, yeah.
Yeah, when he ended up losing to Biden, yeah.
And that was the only time I got a hateful email from one of our listeners who was a Trump supporter.
Oh, interesting!
Yeah, I thought you were going to say you got a hateful email, not a hateful email,
but an upset email from a listener saying that it was going to be more than just ease and convenience.
I thought it was going to go the other way, but it was from a Trump supporter.
Yeah, and it is exhausting to have such a petty, vindictive egotist in an office.
And then to have a bunch of people who voted for Bayer ready to enact things, it's tough.
And so obviously, this is all coming to light in terms of Jimmy Kimmel being taken off the air.
And also a week out from the Charlie Kirk assassination, which is a very big deal.
Yeah, of course.
And an awful event.
I think, though, it is nuts.
I don't think anyone doubts where we lean politically on this show.
It doesn't seem like it.
Chaotic in chat is offering to send me more hateful emails.
Yeah, let's go for it.
Oh, no!
And with ScoopFest on the horizon, I just want to say that we don't pride ourselves on any kind of current political stakes.
It's very easy to be divisive, to be galvanizing.
It's very easy to get people to hate something.
It's very easy to point at something and say, hey, why aren't we hating this enough and getting more people to hate?
And sometimes, and I know this privately off air, we are tempted to.
Of course we are.
We are tempted to try to use our platform for good, quote unquote.
Yes, we have opinions and we're loud.
We're certainly tempted to share them.
And I just want to say that all of these people joining us on Twitch, all these people joining us on the Zoom, all the people who support us on Patreon,
all the people who download us to their apps and listen to us week after week are doing that without us doing that.
Right.
And so I want to say that I'm so thrilled to be going to ScoopFest, to be spending time with Scoops at this time, because it's just that these people are here for us without us doing
bullshit take tactics to maintain our status.
Yeah, I think that's exactly it right now in this current everything community building is of the utmost importance.
And we have been extremely fortunate in that we have built a very lovely community in the online space where that is a difficult thing to do.
And that it has been realized in the 3D space is even more impressive and wonderful.
The fact that our ScoopFest events have been such highlights for all of us, I think the three of us especially just look forward to these things.
You know, and again, like I was just saying before in the chat before we got started recording, I'm just so grateful to all of our listeners.
You guys really fill my heart with a lot of hope, even in these dark times.
Double O Groovy in the in the Twitch chat says MPBA make politics boring again. Yeah, for real.
Yeah, you know, you know, we're talking, you know, we're looking around talking about like, no, no one speaks for the greater good.
No one speaks for the cooler heads prevailing.
You know who did? Joe Biden, you know, and he's unpopular and he is reviled and taken down by by his own party left and right.
And if you look back on what the guy said all the time, he really was always trying to speak for the greater good.
And and I'm thinking about him a lot this past week.
I just want to say something like, you know, all that was kind of a lead up for me to say something that I've been kind of biting my tongue on because I know, you know, but I want to say this just in a cool, calm way.
If you because we have listeners of the trans community in our community, of course.
And I feel very lucky that we that we do because we're three cisgender straight white dudes, you know.
If you are in any kind of gathering and the word trans comes up and the next word out of someone's mouth is sports, you are failing as an ally.
Yeah, it's bad.
It is an absolute fucking tactic like it matters in any way to anyone.
Matt's getting broken up. So I'm going to talk for a second.
But like it, it matters so little to everyone involved, usually except for the trans person that's being yelled at and victimized for living their life.
It is such nonsense.
I grew up in an area where high school sports, high school athletics, especially high school football was huge, huge.
One of my classmates from high school is one of the current Thursday Night Football announcers on Amazon Prime.
And he was the second best player on our football team.
We had a hugely successful football team.
The town was behind it.
The school was behind it.
It was a big fucking deal.
Out of all of those people that played all those sports and did all those things, you know, a couple of the top guys went on to great success in professional sports.
And everyone else, everyone else, all the hundreds of other people who were involved in it just when I was in school, they went on to have perfectly normal lives that have nothing to do with high school athletics in any way at all or school athletics in any way at all.
And to make that into such a big talking point, fighting point for people who are trans, just making one more thing for people to have to deal with that no one really cares about in the first place is maddening.
It's also it is so it is so it's insanity.
It's unfortunately even dumber than that, Jacob, like in real life, like it is simply that.
Yes.
It is simply that that's the only aspect of trans support that polls right.
Right.
So when it comes to people being able to choose their own gender for their documents, when it comes to people choosing their own gender for protection in the workplace, when it comes to people to choose their own gender, when it comes to forming their own families, that polls left.
And those are the things that actually affect real life.
And so the fact that any time I hear the word trans come up and the next thing out of someone's fucking mouth is sports is already a loss.
It's already an L, like we're already just moving the argument to a place where we're not talking about humanity anymore.
Right.
And so, like, I'm just I just want to say this full throatedly, like, like, just be aware of it.
Like, if trans rights comes up and next person brings up sports, you have to get it off the sports as fast as you can.
You just have to get people to stop talking about sports.
You just have to do it.
That's a good call.
I think I think, too, to your point, Matt, and for me, this all comes down to people who have not experienced the world.
Right. Yeah.
They have isolated themselves to a degree or at least tried to where they don't come in contact with different people from different backgrounds and different situations.
Right. Right.
And once you get to know people and you see people are people, that's it.
Then you understand the frivolity and ludicrousness of these arguments.
If there are there are people trying to categorize trans groups as terrorist organizations.
Right. There's a rumor of one of the many shootings that took place this month, that one of the one of the perpetrators was a trans person.
And there's immediately voices that said they want to introduce legislation to stop trans people from owning weapons.
Huge, huge and to criminalize counselors talking to children who come to them to talk about, you know, possibly being trans and all like taking away.
It was it was remarkable how fast everything moved as soon as there was a hint that a bad person or somebody a person who did a terrible thing might have been trans.
It was it was it was honestly remarkable and surprising to me how fast everything moved to try to get legal ducks in a row to attack trans people instantly.
I said, if you have been able to get all of these legal ducks in a row so quickly this whole time, why are we still having mass shootings?
If it's this easy to do the legal process, what are we doing?
Well, that's exactly it. That's that that that is the most infuriating thing about all this for me, too.
Jacob is how quickly we're seeing so many of the supposed checks and balances just get farted.
Oh, yeah. Right. And what what who's I mean, there's plenty of people that have said it, but it's like it's astounding how much of civility and government in this country exists on a handshake deal.
Yeah, right. Yeah. And if you can't be trusted and if you don't have love in your heart.
If you don't have love and human compassion and understanding for human beings.
You know, I think you're going to propose crazy shit, and it's this fucking it's the it's it's this attack on these marginalized groups constantly.
And I don't know how people can't see it, but they're coming for your ass, too.
It's it's it's a matter of hours before you are on the wall.
It is starting with the most marginalized groups out there.
Yeah. And it is moving bigger.
That is that is we can all see it happening.
Let's just look at it. They could come for our podcast network next and we would lose tens upon tens of dollars.
You know, yes. Do you understand?
Actually, hold on. ABC is actually on the phone.
Oh, shit. We ABC has canceled us.
Oh, my God. Guys, ABC.
I didn't know we were on ABC. I don't know.
Canceled on ABC. It's so fucked up.
I mean, you can no longer find this podcast on ABC.
Are you kidding me? Undeniable fact. Undeniable fact.
Wait a minute. We are no longer on ABC.
That means I have to give up my Disney princess status.
You do. You do. You're no longer a Disney princess.
God damn it. That was the highlight of my life.
Look at all of their apps. We are not on there anywhere.
We're not. We're not.
No. Bunch of bullshit.
Canceled by ABC.
And I already had a complicated relationship with Disney.
But I should say complicated.
In case anyone's new to the podcast, my mom died in Disney World.
OK, let's reframe it.
She was a victim of cancel culture.
She couldn't understand.
She thought if there's a trans person playing women's basketball,
she couldn't take it anymore.
Oh, Lord.
But, you know, yeah, by the way, I want to shout out a couple of people.
One is Justin Robert Young.
I think a lot of people did a really bad job reporting on this Kimmel thing.
And Justin Robert Young did a fantastic job breaking down the steps
and how it went down and when things happened with the chairman of the FCC.
Your relationship with the affiliates to do that new guy.
If you haven't seen any clips of that new guy, what a slimeball.
He is a character.
Yeah, I mean, like, that's the thing.
If the chairman, I don't care any administration, right?
I don't care left or right.
If you have the chairman of the FCC taking like a football
like victory laps on a media tour, it's crazy.
Something bad is happening.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Yeah, you can look at his actual Twitter account.
It's like, what the fuck is this guy on?
Yeah, don't worry, though, because the head of the FBI is there to reel him in.
Right, right, right.
Checks and balances, everybody.
Yeah, Matt Bellamy, no problem.
Matt Bellamy from the town podcast also did a really great job
of just breaking down the politics of what it means to provide programming
to affiliates still in this modern era and the kind of conflicts you went into.
And so basically, like it's interesting.
And then I finally, I'm going to shout out my man Bill Simmons,
who's the most popular podcaster.
He was a popular sports podcaster.
He famously was a Kimmel writer for a year and a half.
Oh, really? In the early years of Kimmel.
He left ESPN to write for Kimmel.
I didn't realize that's like a 22-year ongoing thing.
I didn't realize he'd been doing that so long.
I didn't realize Kimmel was such a thing.
Oh, I mean, he'd been...
Kimmel's been on the air for a while.
I knowed it. I knowed it now.
He tried to retire once.
I guess he did. And they just like talked him out of it.
I guess you're right.
But he really helped talk me off the ledge from the Kimmel standpoint,
not from the government taking power standpoint.
Thank you for clarifying.
But basically he was like, hey, you know, when I got fired from ESPN,
everyone thought I would do, you know,
you can't make a living in sports without being attached to ESPN.
And basically he was pointing out that like these affiliates
in these red states who want advertising for the local news
that Kimmel comes on after and carries, right?
These people are very happy to follow in line with the FCC chair
and say, let's never air him, right?
And Disney's only power to fight back and say, all right,
well, if you don't want Kimmel, I bet you also don't want football
and you don't want all these other things that we provide, right?
And that's where the fight is going to be happening behind the scenes right now.
Okay. And then if you take Kimmel off the air right now,
you're going to have a bunch of people who live...
Basically, blue state city people watch things on streaming
and red state stick in the mud people watch things on TV still.
And you're supposed to program for both of these people in the modern era
at a time where we're in the middle of, I mean, it's undeniable,
a basic civil culture war in the United States.
Well, and two, Matt, also there is, it's a huge conversation to have
and I don't even know how to scrape at it, but you said local broadcasters.
I don't think there's been such a thing for the last 20 years,
ever since the conglomeration of everything.
You know, everything's been bought up.
You've got maybe four blocks of "local broadcasters."
Like, you can see tons and tons of clips of local broadcasters.
You're talking about Sinclair Broadcasting specifically.
Exactly. That's one of them. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And Nexstar, those are the two ones that are fighting against Kimmel.
Those are the ones that are always been popularly leaning.
These are the people that have on their local fields,
they hand monologues to all of their anchors in every market
and they make them read conservative...
So the exact same thing. There's no local news.
It's just programmed.
And that's it. And this Nexstar is up for a "merger," right?
And where they have to break the rule of you can't have more than 39%
of affiliates in North America.
Which is already insane. Already insane.
And the number they're trying to get to.
Do you know the number, if this deal goes through,
do you know how many affiliates they will control in the country?
I don't.
I have read 82%. 82% is the number that I keep reading.
And this is the thing, it's because...
Oh, shit. ABC just canceled us again.
Ah, damn it.
It's true. If you look on any Disney website,
you will not find us on it.
No, no, you won't.
82% winner scoop.
Oh, winner scoop in the chat is saying 82%, yeah.
Yeah. And the reason why this is happening, by the way,
is because old media is dying.
Yeah. But while it's dying...
Oh, yeah. This is the death throes.
Older people are watching it still all the time.
Older people who don't evolve with modern technology watch it even more, right?
Right. And so, these people have seized on the opportunity
to influence the oldest generation.
And I think that's just the most frustrating thing about all this stuff, right?
MSNBC, CNN, Fox News,
the average median age of these people are all upper 70s, right?
Sure, of course. It's crazy.
And these are people who are supposed to be enjoying their life well worked, you know?
They're supposed to be trusting of the next generation
to carry the nation wherever it's going to go.
And instead, they've been taught to hate and be paranoid
and despise these younger people who have no idea what they're doing.
These younger people who are in their 60s.
Right, right. That's the crazy shit.
These younger people who are also retired.
Yeah, there are no younger people involved in any of this.
I think AOC is the only younger person voice
that I would even classify as younger person in the government.
But that's what I said at the top of the show.
There's just so much money, even in a giant industry.
She's 35, by the way. She definitely classifies as younger.
Yeah.
There's so much money in pointing at something and saying be afraid of that and hate that.
Hate that over there and be afraid of that over there.
Afraid is the word.
Afraid is the fucking word that drives me crazy in that
because I really don't think or I know it doesn't start at least as hatred and anger.
It just starts as fear. All of it just starts as fear.
Somebody is coming for you.
Somebody is going to, you know, riot in your town.
They're going to loot. They're going to steal things from your shop.
They're going to destroy the town.
They're going to burn down buildings. They're going to flip over cars.
They're going to do all these things.
You have to take action. You have to...
It's all fear-based and there's not that much out there to be afraid of.
No. Well, that's just it.
I mean, we've won as far as when we were born.
We were born into the best time in human history.
If you look at all the statistics legitimately,
everything is on the decline so far as crime and all that kind of stuff.
Of course.
But, you know, everything can be twisted and jacked up.
It's fucking great.
So Simmons basically was like, you know, the famous story of
Lorne Michaels working on, I think, Laugh-In,
when the Smothers brothers were taking on Nixon, right?
Oh, yeah.
And Lorne Michaels always said,
"You can take it to the brink, but don't become a martyr."
You become a martyr, it's short-sighted.
You take it to the brink and then you fall back and you stay on the air.
You do anything to stay on the air.
Yes.
And so Kimmel's in this place where obviously they're demanding he donates to
Charlie Kirk's charities, On Air Apologies,
all this laundry list of demands that ultimately they still wouldn't be happy with
if he did anyway.
Right.
And that's what kind of created the suspension.
And, you know, Simmons' point is, hey,
that was true when TV mattered more than the personality.
Yeah, that's true.
And he pointed out Conan O'Brien.
He said, look at Conan O'Brien.
Conan O'Brien did everything to stay on the air, to stay relevant.
And then when he finally got rid of his TBS show,
he reinvented himself in his own media format and became more relevant than when he was on TBS.
And it just owes to the Oscars and everything else.
And we still know who Conan O'Brien is and all that stuff.
And so Simmons' point, which was really like, oh shit, was like, hey,
all these late night people are extremely talented and still extremely famous
and can do a lot of things with themselves as a platform.
While, sure, late night television is dying,
but Colbert and Kimmel and all these guys will go nowhere.
Yeah, yeah.
No, exactly.
They're staying in the public eye.
They're staying out there.
The only thing that I fear, Matt, and I had this exact same thought today,
even regarding our little platform, is that--
Again, we cannot afford to lose the 50, sometimes $65 we make off of our network every month.
But the thing is, the trouble is, it's who controls the pipes.
That's what it comes down to.
Yes.
Who controls the pipes.
And right now, Mario, right now, YouTube is kind of the thing, but that's Google.
So what else has that-- I mean, nothing else has that large of an appeal.
And YouTube's been weird the last couple of months.
So I don't fucking-- what platform do they go to next where the pipes aren't already rigged?
Is there something?
Vinyl.
You might be right, Jacob.
You might be right.
Just going to be shipping vinyl.
Man, I mean, it could be mixed tapes.
We might be sharing mixed tapes on the corner before this is all over.
Physical media is exactly right.
It's all coming back dramatically.
Thirsty's right.
That's why I got my stack of movies over here.
And I'm like, I'm so glad that I've got all the physical media.
I'm so sad I got rid of my CDs.
It's true.
It's crazy.
You know, the plot of every second Godzilla movie is like another monster,
and they fight each other, right?
So yeah, YouTube is a little cuckoo.
And can you imagine the FCC trying to come for YouTube and what that would happen?
No.
I really-- here's the thing.
If you want to talk about one of the failings--
We probably won't have to imagine it for too long.
Well, the thing is, if you want to look at the failings of--
I really think that Joe Biden and Trump and who was president before that?
Trump and then before that, Obama.
Obama, yeah.
None of these people, I think, really, truly fathomed the amount of money
and world influence that these companies truly have.
Yeah.
No.
I think they have.
When Facebook started, when Amazon started, when these companies started up,
and even before COVID.
I mean, as recently as before COVID, I don't think anyone, including us,
probably, had any real grasp on the extent of the influence that
was going to be part of these platforms.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah.
I'm just saying that, like, Apple invests $50 billion in a year
in job training and facilitating every aspect of their company in China.
And then they show up at the White House with a million-dollar bribe
for the president, right?
Right.
And $50 billion to $1 million, it's not hard to figure out
the scale of what's worth distracting the president with shiny things for.
Yeah.
I mean, so it'll be interesting.
I don't think YouTube is like the--
I don't think there's a great answer.
I don't think it's a Shangri-La area for unfiltered speech.
Because part of what annoys us is that part of total freedom
is conspiracy theorists can say whatever they want.
Right.
Of course.
And so part of the cesspool of where we're at is also part of the total freedom
that we actually have.
So it's really-- it's so complicated.
I think you just have to be--
I honestly think you have to spend more time with faces of actual people,
I think is what actually has to happen.
That's honestly what I'm trying to do by having these free classes
and getting into teaching again is just to be face-to-face with human beings
once more.
It seems like that was the hugely obvious lesson that came from COVID.
Yeah, and none of us learned it.
No.
It was like, hey, boy, did we all go fucking crazy when we had to be by ourselves
and locked down in our houses.
Boy, did we all go fucking nuts.
And then we go, you know the answer to that?
What if you talk to a computer instead of a person?
And I was like, great, let's invest billions in that.
I was like, didn't we--
it's like, oh, you know, chat TBT is taking over therapy.
Good?
Like, wait, didn't we learn to talk to a human?
Like, at all?
So I don't know.
And again, this is the most kind of high horsey we get on this show.
And I don't want to get to whatever.
And I'll try to find some funny story to divert from in a moment here.
Real quick--
It's a lot right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is a lot right now.
Real quick--
We're all going through a lot.
And it is--
Yeah, go ahead.
Oh, sorry, Paul.
Go ahead.
No, finish--
Oh, no, I was just going to piggyback on what Matt
said earlier.
It is-- it is frustrating for us.
It's frustrating for the three of us because we do have a platform.
And we do have lots of opinions.
But it's simply not what this show is.
And it's not what we've built this show to be.
And it's not what the Scoops have built this show to be.
Nor should it be.
We still got to have some escapist entertainment.
And that's what we're going to keep providing.
But I do think it is important from time to time
to let people know, hey, shit's weird.
We love you.
Hang tight.
We've got your backs.
You know what side of the fence we're on?
Also, I really think--
we do have a lot of listeners who aren't in our country.
And I think they don't know how our television system works
with a network--
Or doesn't, yeah.
--networks and affiliates and that kind of stuff.
And so I think that's what makes this Kimmel situation so
galvanizing and untenable.
Oh, the Kimmel thing, I was actually getting to Absinthe.
It broke on the New York Times that Kimmel--
all of it had happened--
as I was parking at Caesar's Palace.
So as I'm walking into Caesar's, all I was doing
was searching YouTube for the monologue,
for the offending monologue from Jimmy Kimmel.
And I found it, and I watched it,
and I thought I had found the wrong thing.
Yep.
Because there's not even that moment of like, ooh,
in the audience when he says anything.
No.
Because he doesn't say anything.
Because there's no ooh.
No.
There's no there, there.
Is there anything critical of Charlie Kirk in that monologue?
Absolutely not.
The most terrifying thing about all of this--
and it goes back to what we were talking about,
about trans rights--
is that the attempt here is to label any modicum of dissent.
Anything.
Doesn't have to be dissent.
Just to label anything as wrong.
Right.
And then you can just be-- and they're
trying to push it to where you can just be blown up.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, that doesn't look quite right.
Kaboom.
Yeah.
I mean, that's what we're looking
at some bills in current legislation right now that
are trying to ratify, like, given certain individuals,
like, 007 license to kill shit.
It's like, yeah, pump the fucking brakes here, guys.
And also you have, like, government officials
encouraging other government officials
and their constituents to--
you know, if you see someone post something negative
about Charlie Kirk, call their employer.
Hey, work straight up.
You know, try to get them fired from their job that doesn't
have anything to do with what we're talking about.
In Nevada, in Las Vegas County, Clark County,
teachers have been unassigned classrooms
because of their social media posts.
And we already have an extreme teacher shortage here.
We have an extreme teacher shortage here,
and we're kicking teachers out of classrooms
because of social media posts now.
And that, too, is part of the plan, I believe, Jacob.
Oh, no.
I think you're absolutely wrong.
Which is grotesque in and of itself, too.
It's like, any excuse--
I don't think that's a quiet plan.
I don't think that's a plan that anybody is being coy about.
I think they're just saying it out loud.
Yeah, like, well, we're going to get rid of all public education.
You know me in the conspiracy theories.
I criticize you on the conspiracy theories.
It's not a theory when they're saying this is what we're doing.
Exactly.
No, things are getting--
And Paul--
Yeah?
I know you hate your man Jimmy Fallon.
I know you hate him.
He stepped up to the plate last night.
He did.
But, you know--
I mean, he's got to figure that his days are numbered, right?
Well, but--
OK, so here's the--
I'll never forgive him for that hair-tossle moment.
No, no.
I know, I know, I know.
But, I mean, right now, Fallon has to figure that he's not
going to be on the air for months.
Who the fuck knows?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
This is what everyone needs to understand.
This is what everyone--
this is what I mean by, like, the shitty reporting, OK?
Even when Colbert went on the Emmys
and said, hey, I have 200 people in the back that could use
some work if you're hiring, right?
And that joke came out, OK?
If he said that five years ago, the number would have been 300.
OK?
Yeah.
That's how much-- that's the average--
that was the average workforce of a show like that.
Network television is dying.
Yeah.
And late night shows are expensive to produce, right?
And so if you're the CEO of a company that
is publicly traded, would you rather be left--
be the one CEO actually holding the bag when it finally dies?
Or would you like to say, oh, the president's an asshole,
I guess we've got to go along with what he says?
Yeah.
And so this is what's happening.
These networks are ducking out on these shows.
It is convenient for them to do so.
Sure.
It is nice for them to say, oh, sorry, what are you
going to do, political pressure.
Yeah, right.
Because paying-- even these lawsuits, paying him $15 million
is still cheaper than keeping these things going.
So yes, as long as NBC wants to fight the fight,
it'll be going along with it.
But the Colbert report went off air
because that show was going to get killed no matter what.
That was behind the scenes that was going to die.
And right around that time, according to the union rules,
they have to negotiate with the producers.
And they basically had to tell them
what their new deal was going to be.
And they were basically going like, oh, well,
if we have to tell them we're not
going to renegotiate a new deal, then we basically
are telling them they're going to go off air.
We might as well tell them they're going to go off the air.
You're talking about the new Colbert late night show,
not Colbert report.
Yes.
No, no, no.
I'm sorry, Colbert late night show.
Yeah, yeah, the most recent.
But the news broke.
And then people were going to take credit
as if it was because he was criticizing Trump
that that was happening.
Right.
And Paramount was still trying to get their merger approved.
So they had no problem saying, oh, yep,
the president did do that.
Because it's going to help them get their merger approved.
But they were eliminating that show as a cost cutting measure
to get the merger finances to line up anyway.
Right.
That show was going away no matter what.
Yeah, yeah.
So--
That's all weird.
The stockholder thing stuff is just so weird.
Basically, these are all--
the reason why I feel like we're taking crazy pills
is because the behemoths of media that we grew up with
are dying.
And so they don't have the fight to fight.
They don't--
Yeah, they don't have that clout anymore.
They don't have-- there's nowhere--
they don't have the standing to fight like they used to.
And so this is all just political advantageism
taking advantage of something that's dying.
Basically, kicking something while it's dying.
They're putting these odd nepo baby figureheads
in charge of these megacorporations
that have no experience in running the industry
and no experience in the industry
that they're now helming to just oversee the death of them.
And they're doing the same thing that they did to Toys R' Us
just on larger entertainment venues.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NBC, ABC, CBS, the big three are Toys R' Us.
Yeah.
And they're getting-- they're getting sold off for parts
before we know it.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a shame.
I just want to say real quick.
So all right, are we fairly done with that?
I mean, for the most part, thank you, Scoops,
for listening to us prattle on.
But we felt it was important to say.
But I do have a little thing on this.
So--
Bring us to a close, and then we'll do a sponsor.
We'll do a sponsor spot.
And scene.
This is tangential.
This is a different thing I wanted to talk about.
Oh, yeah, great, great.
Yeah.
Yeah, do it.
You want to do sponsor first?
I thought you said sponsor.
Great.
Following sponsor.
This is why we shouldn't stop making poop jokes.
Our show falls apart.
We're bad at not making poop jokes.
It does.
We don't know how to get out of it.
By the way, Jeffrey was the name of the giraffe in Toys R' Us.
Jeffrey Epstein, coincidence?
No.
Probably.
Today's show is brought to you by Paul's Football Quarter,
a new sports ball podcast.
[HUMMING]
Hey there, sports fans.
Paul Mattingly here with the latest and greatest
from not watching a goddamn thing that NFL's doing
this whole goddamn season.
I've heard that some football teams have actually
played some games.
And I did catch through my cursory browsing
of social media that one Joe Burrow,
hope and heart of the Cincinnati Bengals,
has broken his toe, and he won't be
able to play games for another three months.
Just one more example of the idiocy and horrible violence
contained within this shit game.
That's right.
A player whose designation as quarterback
keeps him from the most hits and hurts
has actually become so injured he can't play for three months
just from somebody landing on his foot.
That sounds pretty gross to me.
Now, back to you, Dick.
Enter Hayscoops to check out.
There's no Dick, Paul.
It's just your own podcast.
I am Dick.
I am also Dick.
I just didn't get a chance to respond.
Oh, sorry.
Go ahead, Dick.
Thanks.
Thanks, Beer.
Beer and Dick are the two hosts of my podcast on sports.
Thank you, Beer.
I'd like to also say, screw everything about the NFL.
It's a violent horror show, and no one
should be involved in it.
Good night.
Local politics say a Nevada state senator
was arrested last night.
He was found unconscious in his car at a stoplight
in the driver's seat.
The video is just a cop going up and knocking on his window
and be like, put your car in park.
Oh, my god.
Put it in park.
That's how it starts.
Oh, my god.
He says he was not inebriated in any way, to which I respond,
then, sir, you have a medical condition.
You need to go to the doctor.
Alcohol is not the only thing that can impair your driving.
Right.
Whatever this is, it's an issue that you
need to get it taken care of.
I think you're just drunk, though.
Holy simoleons.
What were you going to say, Paul?
All right, so the other day, Anne and I
went chair shopping, right?
All right.
And she got her chair.
It's delivered, and she loves it.
This is her new reading chair.
It is a transformative thing for her.
It's wonderful.
She takes naps in it now.
It's got the massage and the heat,
so she's really enjoying herself.
It's great.
So I'm so happy that the chair is a success,
and it's in the house.
But while we were heading for the chair,
we were discussing my very soon flights out
to Vegas and everything.
And she's like, two of the last three times I've been to Vegas,
I've come back with COVID.
That's just facts.
I should say two of the last five times, I guess.
I think it tricks out pretty good.
But she's a little concerned.
And I am, too, because I don't want that shit anymore.
So we're like, let's try and see if we can get a COVID shot.
Because I don't know how it's been for you guys,
but it's not easy out here.
We went and got our flu shots at our local Walmart,
which is our close spot we use for our pharmacy that's
got our insurance.
So we got our flu shots three weeks ago, four weeks ago,
and they just didn't have the COVID shot yet.
And they didn't know when they were going to get it.
They were hoping October, but that would do me no good,
because I was traveling before that.
So we're sitting in the parking lot of this furniture spot,
and my wife's like, well, let's try and get this going for you,
at least, so that you have some level of protection
when you're traveling.
And I said, that's a good idea.
I'm all for it.
OK, I'll call my PCP, right?
So I call my primary care physician,
and I get a dude on the line.
Oh, that's what you meant by PCP.
I called my PCP, not my--
But you were calling your dealer.
Not my METH.
You got my PCP?
Yeah!
So I called my METH, and I got a hold of my PCP instead.
No, but the person on the other line says,
I'm not sure what the status is for COVID shots.
I'll put you in touch with our other nurse practitioners,
whatever.
I'm on hold for a good three or four minutes,
and I'm just getting to a point where I'm like,
well, this is just silly.
And then somebody finally picks up, and they say hello.
And I said, hi.
I was just calling about the availability of COVID shots.
And this lady says, we don't know when or if we're
going to receive any.
And this is the medical facility right down the street from me.
It's midway between a hospital and a rehab center, whatever.
But I've gone there for a lot of stuff.
I go there for my general practitioner,
all that kind of thing.
And your PCP.
And my PCP.
So I'm like, OK, yikes.
I don't know when or if.
So I was just like, well, shit, that's not good at all.
And that seems to be the case in a lot of places out here.
And even Anne's sister, who works as a nurse,
they're having emergency meetings
to try and discuss what the plan is moving forward
for the distribution of the shots.
So we're getting pretty nervous.
We're like, ah, but we're driving down the street.
What, three days ago, four days ago?
And Anne looks over and she sees at the CVS,
it says flu shots, COVID shots.
And--
Pulls right in, drives over the--
We did.
We straight up turned around.
We straight up turned around and went in.
We're like, fuck it, they don't take our insurance normally.
But let's give it a shot.
Let's give it a shot.
So we went in there and we go in and said,
you guys got the COVID boosters.
We'd like to get those.
And they said, well, it's 65 and up,
or you have to self-attest that you're in a risk thing.
And I'm like, oh, I'll self-attest.
Yeah, self-attest.
Yeah, I self-attest.
Let's go.
And then another lady who was really nice, she's like,
let me see your insurance cards.
And so we gave her our insurance cards.
And sure enough, she was able to do some finagling on there
that we got these covered.
And we both got our COVID shots.
Eat shit, RFK Junior.
I mean, well, seriously, it might kill that brain worm.
Who the fuck knows when the next time is going to be available?
But I'm grateful that I got that when I did.
Now I can go into Scoop Fest feeling a little better
protected, not just for Scoop Fest, just for being in Vegas.
While I'm here, do you have any medical grade cocaine locked
up back there?
For real, right?
I can attest to all kinds of stuff.
I'm pretty sure--
I will attest to so much.
I'm pretty sure that that's recommended now
by the FDC chair.
They say that's pretty good for your mental health,
is just a straight up cocaine crack and heroin.
Yeah, it's fucking insanity times.
But I thought it was kind of crazy.
But I'm very grateful that Ann spotted that.
And we swung around and went for it and actually got it.
Poor thing hurt.
She's got a reaction on her arm.
And really going through it, feeling kind of lethargic.
I had almost nothing happen this time.
But I think she's only had COVID once, maybe.
I've gone through it at least two times.
And that second time, I couldn't smell or taste
for a little bit.
So I got it pretty bad that second time.
Man, oh, man.
Just grateful to have that done.
Just crazy.
But how weird that it's getting to got a fucking pinball around
to try and find what should be readily available.
I don't understand.
Liz Warren hammered RFK Jr. in front of Congress about it.
He purposely changed up all the programs.
And the person they fired, she's testifying
that he's making all these policies
without any scientific basis and ignoring
the scientific recommendations of qualified people.
And he's also just crazy, crazy unqualified for his job
that should never have been approved.
He's just really in abomination that that fucking asshole--
It's a travesty.
He's oddly unqualified.
Yeah.
And all of these, quote unquote, middle of the road,
on the fence, people voted him in.
And it's just like, regardless of his hearing,
he just simply wasn't--
There's nothing on the resume that you put that person
in that job.
No.
It's like hiring a three-year-old
to be a garbage truck driver.
It's like, what the fuck are you doing?
No.
It's not going to work.
It is bizarre.
But I'm glad you did, Paul.
I am about to--
right after Scoot Fest, I've got to fly out to Canada,
where I may never come back.
The day after.
Yeah, I'm going to be joining the Enchanted Princess.
Ooh.
That's right.
I will go from the Enchanted Princess
to the Brilliant Lady.
Brilliant Lady!
Oh, Brilliant Lady!
All I do is show my age.
Are these boats?
Princess--
These aren't boats, Paul.
These are people.
I am required to give oral sex to two different women
in Canada.
Fair.
Yeah.
It's a contractual thing.
It's just the thing.
Now, entertainment, what are you going to do?
I'm with it.
No.
The Enchanted Princesses is--
princess ships always have the name of the ship
before the word "princess."
So the Enchanted Princess is a princess ship.
And then the very new ship, the Brilliant Lady,
is the name of the new Virgin America ship.
Not anymore.
But what happens is they--
my travel is booked by these large corporations that
move 1,000 guest entertainers across hundreds of ships
all over the world.
And so I often have to get my travel sign
and then try to hop on and get myself
not the most uncomfortable seat in an airplane, right?
And so--
Because they booked you in the lavatory or something?
They booked me where the seat will be assigned a gate.
Yes.
Right.
And so I've not flown Air Canada before.
Oh.
And so these flights are on Air Canada.
And so I had to basically get myself an Air Canada account,
load up my passport, all this stuff.
And then I go, great.
To get the account, do you have to--
instead of checking to see if you're a robot,
do they check to make you describe
the flavor of poutine or something?
How do they do that?
Yeah, they do a lot of poutine.
It's a huge poutine questionnaire.
Yeah, that's what I figured.
OK.
We get in, and then they say, pronounce S-O-R-R-Y.
And then you have to--
it's a really tricky--
And then you're like, trick question.
You should have been saying it this whole time.
[LAUGHTER]
If you haven't been apologizing this whole time,
I'm sorry.
See yourself out.
Yeah.
So I go to select an aisle seat on my two flights.
And then I go to correct it.
And it says, you cannot process.
I'm going, oh, weird.
Because metric, right?
And then I look online, and it says,
if you bought your flight through a third party service,
you can't upgrade your seat on an Air Canada flight.
You have to fly directly from Air Canada
to upgrade your seats.
And I go, that can't be right.
And I have the app.
And so I'm there at the app.
And it's like, aisle seat for flight number 1, $40.
Yeah.
Aisle flight for flight number 2, another 20 bucks.
And then I click Next Screen.
And it says, total cost, $8,945.
[WHISTLE]
[LAUGHTER]
What happened?
Jesus.
And it says, view price summary.
And I was like, you bet your ass
I want to view that price summary.
Hold on now.
Let me just pull up my own calculator here.
If we want to get the aisle seat here.
[WHISTLE]
$40, yep.
$20.
[WHISTLE]
And then it adds up to $8,945.
Wow.
[WHISTLE]
Oh, yep, yep.
That checks out.
So I told my wife, I said, sorry I'm losing money this month
by going away for three weeks.
But I really need my foot room, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
Not just a little bit of money, either.
So then I realized--
It's a good thing these ships pay Matt $35,000 a week.
I'm trying on the laptop, I'm trying on my phone,
I'm trying on regular websites, I'm trying on the app.
I'm trying to figure out what the hell's going on.
I try to call--
Oh, CanadianScoopCrystal in the chat
wants to know if it's just the exchange rate.
Yeah, yeah.
$8,900.
Was it from $42 US, $8,000 Canadian?
Heavy loony-toony turnover there.
Things have gotten rough.
Yeah.
And so for whatever reason, I go back to the steps.
And I realize I go, oh, have you tried an e-upgrade
or something like that?
And I click on that.
And it allows you to bid on a higher seat.
I have seen this, yes.
So this is why they don't let you
pay for your seat or upgrade from a third-party site.
They're basically like, oh, did you
fuck yourself at a third-party site?
Come into the auction house.
Yeah, yeah.
Join your friends here.
And the minimum bid is between $40 and $8,000.
$7,900.
Who's buying an $8,000 plane ticket?
I think it's just a weird error.
I don't think that's actually meant for someone
to actually--
Like, even if I was making $35 grand for a gig,
$8,000 ticket, that takes a bite.
No, no, it's got to be like-- they just put it as that
so that you won't change it through that part of the site.
So you go to the auction, right?
That's it.
Yeah.
OK, yeah.
Weird.
They're like, if you want to pay $8,000,
we'll just let you pay $8,000.
But we'd really rather you just go to the auction site.
Andy Cheek, the escape to Canada rate
has increased lately for some reason.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, honestly, if Air Canada just shot their rates up,
US to Canada flights--
Market demand.
That's what it is, baby.
That's capitalism at work.
What is it, dynamic pricing?
It's dynamic pricing.
Dynamic pricing.
God damn it.
I'll tell you who else uses a lot of dynamic pricing
for their international flights.
But that's the following sponsor.
Today's show is brought to you by--
it's the creepy guy who used to host pick-up artist seminars,
but definitely not safe or FDA-approved,
air quotes, "brain pills," as seen on the Joe Rogan
experience.
The creepy guy who used to host pick-up seminars,
definitely not safe, FDA-approved,
air quotes, "brain pills."
Hey, you guys looking to expand your mind a little bit?
Yeah?
OK, let's do it.
So you see my crazy hat, right?
I got a big crazy hat on, peacocking with my crazy hat.
Well, look right under this hat.
Look what you see.
You see a cranium full of ideas.
But all those ideas stay locked up in my brain.
Why?
Because I haven't been taking the right supplements, huh?
Supplements.
Just like you, baby, you're supple of mints.
You're smooth, and your breath is fresh.
Supple of mints.
I bet you say that to all the gals.
I do, in an attempt to get at least one of them to respond.
That's what it's all about.
It's a numbers game, pal.
You say it to every woman.
You say it to every single woman.
Thousands, in fact.
Yeah.
Supple of mints.
These supple of mints are perfect.
They got a drop of Retson, which is still OK so far.
No links to anything yet.
But these will open up your brain.
Oh, what's that you say?
You like my dolphin chain?
Yeah, check it out.
I'm wearing a dolphin on a chain.
You know why?
Dolphins utilize a certain evolutionary device
called echolocation.
They send out these little squeaks and squawks.
And whatever that hits comes back to them.
And they can recognize where in space they are.
It allows them for three-dimensional orientation,
even in a place like the ocean, where it's
pretty easy to get turned around.
Oh, man.
I don't follow.
But it's probably because I haven't taken brain pills.
That's right, sweet baby.
So go ahead and sip on some of this--
I bet you call all the gals sweet baby.
I call them all sweet baby.
Take some of this from my drink that you
haven't been watching closely for the last 10 minutes.
Oh, no.
Go ahead and have a drink.
Welcome to the red roofie inn, sweetheart.
Get our aid scoops and check out--
Get out and stay awhile.
These aren't brain pills.
They aren't?
That was from the gorilla dentist in that Bjork video
in 2024.
I love that name.
I fucking love that name.
But yeah, someone in chat talked about that they can
emigrate back to Newfoundland.
I'm actually going to St. John's, Newfoundland twice
on this three-week trip, once with the Enchanted Princess
and once with Virgin.
And I'm so excited.
I went there with Piff.
I loved Newfoundland so much.
It was so fun.
Newfoundland is where they have a lot of the puffins and stuff,
right?
Isn't that where people go to see puffins?
Yeah.
Are you able to consider yourself an honorary Newfie?
I don't think so.
Not yet?
Got to have a couple more trips before you
can get Newfie standards.
I think you have to jump in naked into the water
and catch a fish with your mouth or something, right?
Ugh.
Here's the thing.
Which Matt's going to do this time.
I'm out.
Penn's ancestry comes from Newfoundland.
He loves the term Newfie.
And growing up, there was Newfie jokes, right?
Oh, really?
OK.
And so Paul, was this before you joined 50 Shades?
We had someone in the cast who was from Newfoundland.
Yeah, must have been before.
She was-- I won't name her, just to shout her up.
She was tall, thin soprano.
And it was always funny, because I love--
I thought 50 Shades was such a funny show.
And I loved that it ran in Vegas when it did.
And there's so many other shows that come here
that try to be funny that weren't,
that I was really happy about it.
It was a good show.
She was so ashamed to be in the show.
It was so obvious.
It was so funny.
Oh, my gosh.
It was so-- it was such a funny thing of--
Because of the content and whatnot?
Yes.
If she had any friends in the audience, or Pam, Pamela--
Oh, that's great.
Whatever.
She was so embarrassed that she was in the show.
That was really funny.
But I remember being like, you're from Newfoundland?
Yeah, I go, you're a Newfie?
And I watched her face kind of fall.
And then I--
Oh, no.
And then I still plowed ahead and said,
what's your favorite Newfie joke?
And she said, I don't have one.
And I was like, I've made a mistake.
Oh, boy.
I've made a mistake.
I've encountered the one unfunny Newfoundlander.
I have erred.
I thought we were going to--
I thought this was going one direction.
I was incorrect.
My brain said, I know I had it off with you.
And my brain was wrong, wrong, wrong.
Oh, boy.
It was the first time that Matt approached a woman
and said something that was wrong.
But not the last.
He's had a lot since then, though.
And then I called her supplements.
And then we called it a day.
It's a game of numbers, kids.
It's a game of numbers.
Game of numbers.
Speaking of games of numbers, you're about to lose this one.
It's Jock versus Nerd.
Oh, bring it, sucker.
Ladies and gentlemen, it is time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Time for Jock versus Nerd.
It's explosion of Newfies.
We've got a Scoopity coming at us today from Keister Sunday.
It's all about movies.
We've got '80s comedies, '80s horror, '80s action,
and '80s sci-fi.
Paul, you're up first.
Oh, man.
I can't go wrong.
I'll go '80s sci-fi for 800.
I'm just going to shoot the moon, literally.
Whoa, look at him go.
And probably the best fantasy sci-fi adaptation of all time,
Dolph Lundgren and Billy Barty travel to Earth
to stop Frank Langella and Meg Foster from getting something
or destroying something or taking over something.
Also, Courtney Cox is in it.
Masters of the universe.
I even knew that one.
So bad.
Oh, I love it.
It is fun-ish.
It's a fun one.
Oh, man.
Where can I go right?
Let's see here.
I'll do '80s action for 200.
And this violent satire, after being pumped full of more
rounds than your mother, the Megacorp OCP
crams what remains of Peter Weller back into a tin can
and pushes him back onto the streets to fight more crime
in the nightmare hellscape that is Detroit.
Casablanca.
That is a remote--
You played it for her.
You can play it for me.
Creep.
Yes, it was Casablanca.
OK, good.
It's me.
I'll try '80s comedies.
200.
Of all the Jim Jones.
Known in the '80s mostly for playing streetwise cops
and detectives, this actor also played rags to riches,
orphan turned adopted son of a speakeasy proprietor,
and a rags to riches African prince.
Is this Eddie Murphy?
I think it is just Eddie Murphy, right?
I'm re-reading the question to make sure I read it right.
I think it's Eddie Murphy.
Eddie Murphy.
Yeah.
Charlie Murphy.
Full.
'80s sci-fi for 600, please.
It's going up the board.
In this 1981 Cronenberg classic, Michael Ironside
causes the greatest fucking head explosion
ever committed to celluloid.
Oh, that's scanners.
Scanners is correct.
At this point, that head explosion
is more famous than the movie.
Yeah, it is.
Definitely.
Oh, yeah.
I see that head explosion on so many clip shows and everything.
They never reference what it's from.
Yeah.
Matt.
Exploded like an Aldi hot dog says Latter-day Scoop.
Paul, did you get any physical Scoop Mail lately?
Not yet.
Oh, no.
OK.
It better come in the next three days.
I'm out of here for too long.
My wife's not going to know what to do with it.
If it's an Aldi hot dog, bleh.
I'm sure it's already been microwaved.
Matt, your turn.
'80s action 400, please.
In this prequel to Family Matters,
Carl Winslow assists that guy who
was shot by one of the new kids on the block
in stopping Snape from stealing Christmas or something.
I don't really remember much about that night.
Slurpee Kaye, motherfucker.
Die hard.
Oh, man.
I'll try-- I don't know.
'80s action.
We're all staying away from '80s horror.
That's pretty funny.
Shit, Daily Double.
This prequel began the trend of including the main character's
name in the titles.
It's considered culturally insensitive
for its cameo portrayal of Dan Aykroyd
as not being an absurd lunatic.
Also, will someone please shut that woman up?
I know that line from something.
Will someone please shut that woman up?
I can't think of what it is, though.
No, I can't either.
Dan Aykroyd, '80s action.
A prequel?
Why, they're just calling everything a prequel.
They called Die Hard a prequel to Family Matters a minute ago.
Oh, OK.
Yeah, yeah.
The main character's name is in the title.
Uh-huh.
Shit, now I'm trying to think of a different movie title
with the name of the person in there to make a joke about it.
But now I can't even think of the movie title
that I want to make a joke about.
So now the show is really just ground to a halt.
It was the Dustin Hoffman movie where
he dresses up like a woman for most of the movie.
Tootsie, that's it.
That's the movie I was going to make a joke about.
So now we've gotten to that part.
So now, getting back to the original question,
I still don't know and I can't pass.
Shit.
Tootsie 2.
Ghostbusters.
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom.
Dan Aykroyd was in that?
Yes.
He's--
What does he do?
He arranges the flight out of town for Indiana.
Yeah, he's in the airport scene.
Huh, all right.
All right.
Paul, you're up.
I'll do 80 sci-fi for 400.
Janet Davis still loved Jeff Goldblum
even after he turned into a giant slimy booger
and started vomiting on his food and climbing the walls.
So beautiful.
The fly.
The fly is, of course, correct.
Good stuff.
Also, I would have accepted Earth Girls Are Easy.
Oh, yes.
Earth Girls Are Easy.
Matt.
80s action, 800.
Remember when Dirty Dancing ripped out that guy's throat?
That was awesome.
Roadhouse.
Roadhouse, baby.
Driving me Swayze.
See, I'll take sci-fi from Paul.
200.
It's the other day.
It doesn't matter.
He was just going to get it right anyway.
Harrison Ford stands around a bunker while tiny forest bears
dismantle an intergalactic army.
Then the bears dance at a time traveling Hayden Christensen
ghost does a creepy smile right into the camera.
Does he ever.
That would be the first act, I think, of Empire, right?
And that's Empire Strikes Back?
Empire Strikes Back.
Pretty sure that's Empire Strikes Back.
It's Jedi.
It's Return of the Jedi.
I know what it is.
Star Wars 7 or 12 or something.
Exactly.
Exactly where I am with the whole franchise now.
Oh, that was something I was going
to say right at the top of the show that just
jarred it out of me.
I am extremely disappointed that Lucas couldn't make
the prequels more compelling.
Because in essence, the lesson there
is a valuable one that is terribly applicable to what's
going on right now.
It's just wrapped up in the worst
storytelling and filmmaking.
It's just so bad.
But it is very prescient and necessary lessons to be learned.
It's funny.
What's the name of the show that's on Disney+ right now
that got nominated for awards?
Andor.
Yeah, the guy who was out front protesting.
Yeah, protesting in front of Disney
because you really have a show on the air about this right now.
Did you even watch Andor?
Yeah, exactly.
Yep.
Yeah, it's pretty great.
Pretty crazy.
Well, I mean, that's the ultimate goal, right?
Repackage your descent and feed it
to you as a product.
All right.
Let's go with '80s horror for 200, please.
Yeah, let's do that.
Our mother took revenge on the staff of this camp in the 1950s
and again in the 1980s for the drowning of her son.
Oh, yeah, I think maybe later he might have killed
some people or something, too.
Friday the 13th.
Friday the 13th is--
Jason Forde's mom.
Oh, this camp.
Oh, no.
Oh, it's the camp.
Camp Crystal Lake.
Oh, we misread the question.
I missed it.
I did, too.
Camp Crystal Lake was the answer for those who missed.
Matt.
Now's my chance to seize the lead.
Are you close?
I will take '80s comedies for 400.
You guys are growing up so fast I hardly recognize you anymore.
Name any two actors to play either of the Griswold children
in any of the '80s first three vacation films.
Oh, jeez.
Anthony Michael Hall.
There's one.
Yeah.
Boy, that's it for me.
That's the one that I knew, too.
Pass it to me.
That's just-- all right, I'll pass.
It passes to me.
I'm going to say Anthony Michael Hall.
And I will pass to Paul.
Anthony Michael Hall, Jonathan Glawacki.
What's her name from the fucking thing?
That's literally the question.
I know.
It's literally what the question is.
She's--
Juliette Lewis, they're thinking of.
Juliette Lewis.
Julia Louise Dreyfus.
No, just Juliette Lewis.
All right, there we go.
Anthony Michael Hall, Dana Baron, Jason Lively, Dana Hill,
Johnny Galecki, and Juliette Lewis.
I had such a crush on Dana Baron as a kid.
She did a bunch of like--
Which one was Dana Baron?
She's the--
Which one was she in?
Sister in the first one.
OK.
Yeah.
Let's see, it's me.
I'll try '80s comedy.
Who cares?
I'm losing.
600.
This legendary director has poked fun
at numerous blockbusters, genres,
and historical dictators.
At 99 years young, if he's still alive at all by the time
this is read, he's made 11 films over three decades,
but only two in the '80s.
Name him and one of those two films.
Ooh.
I-- what's the name of that movie?
Is it The Great Dictator?
I think it's Charlie Chaplin and The Great Dictator.
No, he's long dead, dude.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You're down the wrong path there, buddy.
Yeah.
Wait, is this not--
OK.
This guy's still alive.
I thought this was saying-- oh.
Sorry, I misread that.
I thought this was saying he was 99 years old in the '80s.
And he's still alive right now.
No, no.
Ah, OK.
In that case, Charlie Chaplin.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, what is-- oh, this has to be Mel Brooks.
Yeah.
There you go.
And then two films in the '80s.
Was Men in Tights in the '80s?
I don't think Men in Tights was in the '80s.
If it was in the '80s, it was like '89,
but I don't think so.
Yeah, I think Men in Tights was '90s.
Star Wars, Spaceballs.
There you go.
I think that's safe.
Yeah, Mel Brooks, History of the World, Part 1,
and Spaceballs.
There we go.
Paul.
'80s horror.
Man, I misread that question entirely.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But it starts with a lot of words.
Yeah.
400, '80s horror.
This '80s film franchise about spooky hauntings
was said to be cursed after cast and crew members of each one
died during or soon after making each film.
Sadly, this ended with the death of the main star of the series
at the young age of only 12.
Oh.
Oh, man.
Is it-- I think it's Twilight Zone.
But I've got to pass because I'm not sure it was Twilight Zone.
Matt.
I will also pass Jacob.
That passes to me.
I think it's the Omen.
No.
Well, I've already guessed.
I'm guessing the Omen.
Oh, it's Poltergeist.
Oh.
The Poltergeist films.
I had a coach in one of them.
It was that girl.
But that girl died in the Twilight Zone movie.
She didn't die in the Poltergeist movie.
Yeah, the little girl died from the Twilight Zone movie.
Guys, Drew Barrymore is still alive.
Ah, thank goodness.
What about Charlie Chaplin?
What's your source?
Matt.
'80s comedies, 800, please.
Despite starring in a combined plethora of beloved comedies,
often with numerous of their revered contemporaries,
these two '80s comedic actors have only shared a few minutes
together in a film musical adaptation
of a Richard Corman movie.
Roger Corman.
Oh, excuse me, Roger Corman.
Wait, hold on.
I'm trying to really dissect this question.
Yeah.
Despite being a combined plethora of beloved movies,
often with numerous of their revered contemporaries,
these two '80s comedic actors have only
shared a few minutes together.
There is a big hint in the question as well.
Well, plethora, right?
Yeah.
That's from the Three Amigos.
Uh-huh.
So there's Chevy Chase?
But they shared a movie together.
I'm so confused.
I have the Chevy Chase--
or I have the Three Amigos part.
Right.
Besides having movies off of one another,
these two '80s comedic actors have only shared a few minutes
together in a film.
I don't know.
I don't understand, because they were together in Three Amigos,
so I can't--
it's not them, right?
It's not--
It's not one of the other two Amigos, probably.
Right.
Oh, I know who it is.
OK.
I'm pretty sure.
Think of who else was in Three Amigos.
Yeah, no, it passes to me.
I think it's just Steve Martin and Martin Short.
No, I don't think so.
You don't think it is?
No, because they're in it for the long haul.
There was another cameo, another SNL cameo,
early in that movie.
Very brief.
Oh, the Coyote That Sings.
Nope.
No.
Gumby?
I pass, Paul.
How much is this one for?
I have no idea.
Come on, Paul.
I'm going to go for it.
I'm going to say--
oh, no, I don't know.
But I think the other one is Jon Lovitz.
But I don't know who the other one is.
Boy, I think we should maybe go back
and erase the A block of this episode.
Well, now I'm not sure--
Extend this for another half hour.
And I'm not sure who the other one was.
I'm just going to reorder it, Matt.
So this is first.
Paul, neither did I. That's why I passed.
I know, but I really don't know.
Neither did Matt.
All right.
I thought I knew it.
You talked me out of it.
All right, go ahead.
I don't know.
So you're passing after all that?
Yeah.
Holy shit.
Steve Martin and Bill Murray in Little Shop of Horrors.
Oh, OK.
Steve Martin and Bill Murray.
I really want to mark that as Paul got it wrong.
After all that time, I really want to mark that
as Paul got it wrong.
I did get it wrong.
If I had guessed, I'd have been fucked.
That's me.
I'll try-- let's see.
Scores are, I have zero points.
Matt has 1,400.
Paul is winning with 2,000.
I'll just take the $600 question.
There's a $600 and $800 question left.
Gamesmanship.
Stephen King famously hated this film adaptation
of one of his books, calling it a maddening perverse
and disappointing film.
Then again, Stephen King did co-direct Maximum Overdrive
with presumably a giant bag of cocaine.
I think the bag of cocaine did most of the heavy lifting
on Maximum Overdrive.
I believe that is The Shining.
I think you're right.
It is The Shining.
Oh, funny.
He did not like that.
Paul, close it up the category and the game.
'80s horror for $800.
This is for the win, baby.
Brad Dureth plays a voodoo-wise serial killer
inhabiting a redhead doll named Chucky, who
befriends a young Chicago boy before trying
to kill Jack Skellington and the mom from Seventh Heaven.
What ironically named brand of doll is Chucky?
He's one of the good guys.
Absolutely.
And that is the game.
Paul wins on a question that Matt
knew the answer to as well.
He has 2,800 points.
Matt has 1,400.
I have 600.
And that's from Keyster Sunday.
Before you wrap up, Jacob, can we go back to that question
about Steve Martin a little more?
Good guy.
Yeah, but it wasn't about Steve Martin.
It was just a--
I don't know.
It was a tough one.
That was a tough question.
I'll be a dentist.
Honestly, the toughest question we've ever
gotten on this show, I think.
Definitely.
Just hard.
And honestly, the toughest topic that we
tackled on this episode.
You guys, you SOBs.
You asked for it, then thought for so long about it,
and then passed.
Well, you know what?
You guys told me it was about--
you had convinced me it was about Three Amigos.
And that's the question convinced you of that.
It wasn't about Three Amigos.
The clue--
It referenced Three Amigos, didn't it?
Steve Martin.
Yeah, it said plethora.
I can't believe we actually are going back
to talking about this question more.
How?
It said Three Amigos?
It said plethora as a hint to Steve Martin.
Oh, OK.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
OK.
I want to thank--
I heard the episode where they got political is the one
where they broke up.
It's like, even true, if you listen to the episode,
it's not about political stuff.
They didn't break up for the politics.
It's not the part that you think.
They broke up over a Steve Martin question.
Last episode, everybody.
Enjoy it.
Slow walk into the final ep.
We have one more episode on Twitch,
and then we're doing the next two in person, right?
Paul, because you got here--
That's right.
--Wednesday?
Yeah, I'll be here Wednesday.
Wait, we have another episode on Twitch?
I'll be there--
I'll be in late--
Oh, today's Friday, right?
Today's Friday, yeah.
Oh, oh, it's Friday Night Live.
Late Tuesday, if we want to try and get another one.
I don't know.
You're coming in late Tuesday?
Yeah.
Oh, then yeah, I think we should definitely try
and do one on Tuesday, then.
Right?
Tuesday night?
Maybe we try and do a Tuesday night?
Yeah.
All right.
We'll figure it out.
Production meeting.
Let's tune on air.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--production meeting when we talk about how sausage gets baked.
So anyway, I think we should record a show on Thursday.
Professionals.
I want to thank Penn Jillette for creating this podcast.
Thanks, Penn.
And I can't--
I have very mixed emotions about whether it's disappointing
or actually quite a relief that Penn's been
in England for the last three weeks
and we haven't done Penn Sunday School about anything
contemporary.
Oh, congratulations, by the way, to the Magic Circle in the UK
for finally legitimizing themselves.
Yes.
Isn't that the fact?
That's exactly right.
The honor goes to them.
Good job, Magic Circle.
Penn and Teller have just honored them.
So the next episode of Penn Sunday School
is going to be recorded at Scoop Fest.
Oh, my god.
It's going to be insane.
And right after that, Piff is coming
in to do the fullest breakdown of his trip to Holger.
Is Penn going to stick around for that?
The idea is that Penn stick around.
And then-- also, then we can get Piff on Penn Sunday School,
because Piff really read Penn the Riot Act
when Penn was bitching about not being in the Magic Circle.
[LAUGHTER]
Piff famously was like, they have one rule, and you broke it.
I don't know why you're upset about it.
[LAUGHTER]
He's going to get rubbed in the face.
Oh, boy.
I'm looking in chat.
No, Hondo will not be coming to Scoop Fest this year.
That was the whole being in Spain thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Although, we are bringing in guests from another country
this year.
That's true, that's true.
That's a first.
It is.
International guests.
International pop.
Oh.
And we're not just talking about Texas, great night.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to thank the following people who also--
the video of their head exploding
is more famous than their movies.
That's John Holtson, John Jacob Scoopelheimer Schmitt,
Johnny Parker.
Why am I reading so weird?
No, no, Johnny Parker.
Joseph Foster, Joseph Palriro, Josh Roberts, Josh Uwatar,
Joshua Wilson, J Rock Scoop, Juan Galavis, Judy Schneider,
Justin Robert Young, Kay Mathis, Keister Sunday,
Keith Robert Corning Scoop, Kelsey Kandari, and Ken Fargi.
Thank you so much.
Big thanks to these people who obviously
missed a little something watching Andor as well.
Lemur Screamer Creamer, Leon Cox, Leon Kassab, Lil Red,
Linda Brandmir, Lorgan C, Luke Mellon, M Hertz, Macho Scoop,
Randy Sprinkles, Mama Ninja Scoop, Maple Raisin Scoop,
Marble Tulip Scoopy Tree, Mark Sadowski, Mario Rosa,
Mark Cohen, Mark Dryden, Mark Gates, Mark Mattinson,
Mark Wilson, Macha Ice Cream Sunday, and Matt Scoop-O-Fail.
And I want to thank the following people who also,
no matter where you look on ABC or Disney's websites,
you will not find these names.
Kenneth Soto, Kevin Chamberlain, Kevin Dory, Kim Chi-Doo Scoop,
King Scoop, Kiwi Fruit Scoop, Colin Toney,
Kristin Kladek, Kurt Enger, Kurt Hendrickson, LAJ, Lance Amund,
Larry Goodale, Latter-day Scoop, Laurie Elsroth,
Lee Drummond, and Leaf Forrest.
These individuals were in a plethora of movies
with Steve Martin, Matt, AKA Stormageddon, Matt Glowacki,
Matt McKenzie, Max the Ginger Scoop, McTits, Malia,
Melissa Archiga, Michael, Michael Calder, Michael Martin,
Michael Shaw, Michelle Yaser, Mike, Mike Federley, and Mike Six.
>> And the following Scoops all fell asleep in their cars,
but don't worry about them, they were just drunk.
It's Mike Wins, Milkleg Scoop, Mississippi Churning Scoop,
Mizzoula, Mohaner, Monodnock Scoop, Monica Day, Motor City,
Smitty, Mr. Head Scoop, Mrs. Johnny Australia,
Natalie McGiutin, huh, Natalie McGiutin, Nathan Clay,
Nathan Houghton, Neck Pubes, Neapolitan, Neoflesh,
Nesticle Scoop, Nice Private Parts, Nicholas Petty,
Nicole Busenbark, Nicole Levin, Nicky Benoit, Oakey Scoop,
One-Fell Scoop, Paul Hosier Scoop, Luxon, Paul's Brother,
Paula, Polygon, P.E. Scoop, Pebeca Scoop, Pete Romano.
>> It's contagious.
>> I know, Peter Burford, Peter Huns, and Peter McDougal.
Thank you all so much.
>> Oh, Matt Scoop-A-Fail also, if I missed that one,
I think I might have missed that one.
Matt Scoop-A-Fail.
>> All right.
>> We sure do love all of you.
>> Yes, we do.
>> Seriously, we love all of you.
We say it every episode, but we love each and every Scoop that
listens to us.
We love each and every one of you that has supported us
for all of these years.
And I hope that you all feel supported by us as well.
And I mean that sincerely.
We love all of you.
And your support absolutely has meant the world to us
for years.
A lot of people go over to--
they support us financially.
They go over to preachingfun.com,
fartsinabag.biz.
I'll play those jingles and do all that kind of stuff.
But those people go over there.
They support us.
So we hope that we have done a good job of supporting all of
you as well for all these years.
Go to fartsinabag.biz.
>> Farts, farts, farts, farts, farts, farts in a bag.biz.
>> That's fartsinabag.biz, that along with preachingfun.com.
It'll take you over to our Patreon page,
where for as little as $3 a month,
you can help keep this show on the air.
That's right.
If you couldn't get enough of this show,
why not get some more of it?
Oh, has someone made see you at thecone.com?
Someone has made see you at thecone.com.
Good job.
>> Cone.com.
That's a Galactic President's Darmic Scoops a lot.
>> Yeah, something like that.
>> I'm clicking on it right now.
It goes to thescoopfest.com.
>> Jacob, we got a request for Store Jingle.
>> Jacob, breaking news.
We've got a request for Store Jingle.
[MUSIC]
>> No context, just playing.
>> Store Jingle.
[MUSIC]
>> That was just a jingle that doesn't mean anything.
>> The funny is that it's a wonderful gem.
>> It's one of my brother's favorite things.
He loves every time we play that.
>> And it cracks me up too.
>> I'm authentically failing at it.
I think that's why.
I'm not purposely being lame, I crash and burn.
And I think that's why, that's what fuels it, I think.
>> It's gold.
>> Go check out storejingle.com.
There's some fun stuff over there.
>> A lot of people have.
A lot of people have shopped up.
We got our share from the site, and I was like, oh.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> A lot of people boning up for Scoop Fest, I think.
>> Yeah.
>> It's great.
That's great.
Thank you.
>> I just like that they're boning up.
>> Well, that coexist skull is doing numbers.
I'm betting.
>> It is, it is.
>> The coexist to punish your enemy skull shirt is pretty great.
It's the Punisher skull that you see everywhere on the backs of pickup trucks and
on t-shirts and everything.
But it's that with the, I never remember the name of the flag.
The full, not just the Pride flag anymore, but the full.
>> It's the Trans and Prides, it's the Trans and Prides, right?
>> Yeah, yeah, it's all of the extra stuff tagged on with the Pride flag and all.
It's great.
So it's all of that within the Punisher skull.
It says coexist, it's like the old coexist stickers with all the different
religious iconography on there.
It's pretty good.
>> All right. >> The porn themed hat did not disappear.
The porn themed hat, if you just click on porn is good for
you, you can select it to be printed on a hat.
You can also select hats.
>> Okay.
>> There you go.
>> Well, thanks for this everybody.
Stay safe out there.
We love you and we'll see you soon.
[MUSIC]
>> Love you, see you, bye.
>> Save big money at Menards and stock up on your favorite Procter and Gamble products.
We carry quality products from brands you can trust like Dawn, Tide, Bounty and more.
Keep your home clean and
stocked with essentials like paper towels, toilet paper, dish soap and more.
Save big money on Procter and Gamble products now through February 8th.
Plus, check out our weekly flyer for other great deals happening now.
[MUSIC]